over here oh [ __ ] okay here we go
[ __ ] I'll come down connection ah all
right let me know
again this girl out I should be if it's
too loud not too loud where is everybody
funny to turn you [ __ ] down I'll do
that alright alright sniffing hey Frank
oh there's top come in let's go bananas
oh yeah hold a hunk Frank and I were
still we're almost done okay
yeah go tell my a my they're almost
alive
there's God dude
they're probably around their sister
Colin oh I am live here we go hi there I
am this is for you Griffin Jamie all
right let me know how I'm doing people
oh is that okay wait was that for me
yeah oh that wasn't for me who sent me
an info now that was for banana and
Arthur all right do it sound good -
sounds good I'm gonna invite Griffin
coke and Mike Griffin so he can join you
and the circle ring can join you all
right think we're in we're sounding good
Griffin gaming ethnic legends join join
coke Griffin and I just did Frank will
jump in with you oh I got three believes
that's cool it didn't change though I
accepted his thing but it didn't wait
let me go here hold up
it's like so many different people
inviting me how come he did anyway I
guess I have to exit this I don't
understand what the [ __ ] happening if
you card yeah Oh showing game there we
go there we go there we go now I'm in
I'm sending one to the rest to you
good evening everybody that's listening
to referred word Griffin this is not
riffing with Griffin this is Griffin
gaming with my worst fire team Jersey on
I'm the only one wearing to Jersey are
you playing right now are do you piece
of [ __ ] nobody yep so far to go Frank
wait we're waiting for Frank I thought
Frank was gonna be in this game he's
still playing oh my god this is
ridiculous all right guys we're still
playing this ridiculous game apex
legends well maybe we should just start
a practice match anyway coke my bananas
here Arthur we'll see you later
let's go banana we'll get somebody
they're just random let's just get a
practice match right oh you are oh I see
you you're like your own characters all
knelt down in homage to me says you're
still an [ __ ] yeah yeah I got a black
[Music]
that's how let's get a dough be vulgar
let's go you do run so far he's being a
dick yeah that's what I'm saying
what's on your storage so much this
match is gonna be here
while we got some random way I'm
supposed to select I want to be this guy
cancer my system
[Music]
[Laughter]
do we want this clown to be the
jumpmaster
that doesn't seem right what the [ __ ] is
playing dude I've sent like five minutes
some dude what randos oh my god dude
why aren't you I just left that stupid
match there's a black screen where's
Frankie about your break oh I don't want
it I don't want any lip bro wait what is
this [ __ ] okay I gotta open packs guys
[Music]
all this mean how do I do all this stuff
to craft materials what is all this [ __ ]
yeah what is all this I don't know what
I'm doing I don't know what all this
stuff is for skin oh I get it
pick some Rando and he's not dropping
what are you supposed to do it Oh
equipped okay I see oh okay
I can't I can't do all this guys I'm not
gonna be
I'm gonna go do stuff cuz you I don't
know why you just randomly jump this
okay I'm like equipping [ __ ] but I don't
know what it is what do you do just
crafting materials like just sitting
there
no I'm do you see me keeper
it's over okay people are telling me
it's skins for guns I'm with you right
here and I got that super chat enabled
so I'm all about upstairs even any
donation you'd like to give donation
blog alright what I want we want to be
disguised oh yeah why does he get to use
first it's just the order that you get
the fix we dukakis my first wing this
blue circle power insurgence please
helmet
like I'm the I'm the chap okay here we
go jump you jump master okay we'll take
us someplace yeah yeah I will take us
someplace
we're gonna go slum lates bro I don't
want that either yeah it probably shoddy
yeah let's do this
there was one area here
what is that
[Music]
oh I love this tandem jumping it just
looks delicious you get that sighs okay
just chat let me know how the volume is
everything if it's a good sign
Pikachu can you please check car got a
squat where's the funny oh I see yeah oh
[ __ ] oh yeah I got away the guy was
ziplining I was on a zipline and he shot
me because the guy had a gun when we
landed I was shooting me up dead
okay well that's how you uh start guys
I'm dead we literally I don't want to
watch this [ __ ] just get out of here how
do we leave this it's the worst a lot of
a go how can there be echo oh my god I
just donated you five bucks Griffin
looking at your chat I'm looking but it
doesn't it should pop up should be like
five bucks
thank you cam any echo oh wait wait wait
I see what the problem is
hello wait what is happening I don't
know what the problem is
my god I'm gonna hit my Selden's right
here yeah what is happening with this
army start oh I'm ready to go when
you're ready yeah and I feel like a chew
right now I've had a two in a while time
to dip Griffin Swain with you there's no
plane with you guys you're stressing me
out
but what talking sounds like [ __ ] number
a newtonian you told my audio we'll
figure this [ __ ] out a venture a lot but
for now yeah sitting in the game now
it's a little hot drop Frank I know what
it is I know what it was there come in
grenade grenade okay whose are you the
jumpmaster good yeah we're done right
master or go I'm with I'm with you I
just gotta get a gun right away as my
[ __ ] problem he's right there over
here
oh [ __ ] I'm in some weird are we up here
oh [ __ ] I just fell I don't know a
Chancellor ham if you want to play it be
a banana you can oh here we go here we
go here we go here we go oh yeah these
cases ah I got it
I got a ninja star all right okay Mulder
let's go let's go let's do it get a gun
I got a gun okay I got a gun
okay where are you coke I got a gun I'm
up top all right just like eight there's
a bunch of things down here we call it
uh supply things oh I got blue armor I
got all blue armor first blood oh [ __ ]
here we go we just start again you
invited March the [ __ ] are you doing
I'm in a game still there's seven squads
left like we're supposed to be like
you know please you know what I mean get
rid of I don't know what to get rid of
right here wait barrel stabilizer ham
shotgun with died I didn't die
how you gonna fight him if you're in a
game Arthur there's like there's a blue
thing up here man now you're moving oh
my god okay well you want to tell me
this is like the woman this is what I'm
talking what I'm in the middle of
gathering weapons in an armor and you're
already gone Jesus cuz I'm in the middle
of doing [ __ ] friendly fire was on throw
a grenade and [ __ ] blow em up we go
make it damn it no we're gonna be short
but that's alright we get started the
swamp you should drop off dude control
next time give me that that was that you
you don't have the gun I was going there
why did you notice how they're gone
already de stream no no no like moving
out team nothing you know I mean [ __ ] it
but look we're together so that must
mean something here there's a guy in
front of me nothing we're together
and I die right now yeah so he's sick in
the L and playing with the random that
joined see how he's like all like I
can't even look for anything because
some of the [ __ ] already go just got
a stay yes all right there's a fit so
there's a bunch of [ __ ] here oh right
behind you piece of [ __ ] if you didn't
see if you were a good squad leader you
would know that I'm here oh oh [ __ ]
somebody shoot me hey what is going on
oh that's a soom thing trying to get my
first win
[Laughter]
what's up everybody who's talking what
Rando is talking right now
[ __ ] ignore I ignore all Rando you
don't talk to me you talk to you talk to
Pikachu you talk to me and then we have
worst fire team ever
good job Arthur way to be I'm here is
here yes oh now he wants to be a team
player
all right guys
dammit now I got picked Craig Oh Dan so
here's the shift it's somebody on the
ship no anybody on this oh there's like
a purple thing here oh you got some four
kills going there came to pick that up
well we're in the circle right we're
good
where are you Oh these [ __ ]
already left me guys I'm still on the
[ __ ] ship I'm still on the ship and
his mother [ __ ] already in another
field quiet
you were on the champagne poppers no
keep going
here we go no they're dry let's go left
go left [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] up all these
guns are dope okay what am I supposed to
do right now you're not jumping anymore
vulgar damn it oh my god I don't know
what to do right now do I just leave him
like he would leave me okay I'll jump I
need some more ammo or think I need some
oh I have there's there's some like
there's some people [ __ ] over here man
out like this guy had up just yeah
purple okay they just I don't have
anything either on the other side you
know got [ __ ] you want check out those
guys over there
oh I'm black now they're just I have no
ammo in this gun Jesus Christ
wait I gotta see if I can get my ammo
there we go Oh
oh my god
okay I think you came from the back side
of me oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I put my shield up
get over here oh [ __ ] my oh my god oh my
god okay
I come going behind this there there's
another guy over here 104 104 all right
he got me oh my god
it's from his Frank playing with you
guys I'm waiting recovery oh my god this
game is infuriating
I don't know man
auntie vac and I still be recovered you
can still recover me over your [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you know over here yeah you don't let me
know let somebody [ __ ] know
where you at dude well I'm busy looking
around and your ass just revive me
[ __ ]
okay that's what you need to do it here
our car oh this means flying in oh this
is weird
oh [ __ ] all [ __ ] telling me that I
make them feel like they suck less at
this game way too I lose all my guns Oh
should I gotta get back to the ring they
drop me outside of the ring oh my god
I'm about to die cuz I'm not in the ring
dude I swear to god I don't even have a
weapon
alright dude I'm about to die
dude I'm running towards the ring and
the ring is like [ __ ] beating me it's
a [ __ ] armored I don't have a gun oh
my god I'm about to die and I have no
power
oh [ __ ]
alright can I get in a ring I'm about to
die dude this thing was already on me oh
my god I have to rejoice my shields and
I don't have a [ __ ] there's a
different rates over here I've got a
crate I found a crate y'all okay here we
go give me that what I'm what the [ __ ]
this is but I'll take it no [ __ ] guns
obvious of course it's so ridiculous
people I love people in my stream
stating the obvious you're the worst
gamer I've ever seen in my life good
dude just no guns all I have is like
[ __ ] damn it I don't want this variable
Darrell Stokes stabilizers and there's
no guns can I get a gun oh my god
there's no guns code I don't have any
guns okay okay I gotta get rid of this
[ __ ] I just dropped a bunch of [ __ ] that
I don't
oh I'm coming for that [ __ ] okay
all right give me this I already have
that okay I don't have a gun it's like
all I have was a termite we need ya the
wing man right there oh my god where I
have a gun I stood there was no gun in
this for go there is a gun you're right
hey we're back I saw the gun you know I
have no problem saying I was wrong about
that
you know you need to learn a lesson from
that you're wrong all right okay
you only got about 20 seconds oh my lord
I I need to [ __ ] oh it's all in the
rocks
wait where is it I'm so turned around
now oh oh well you just marked another
one we're close
oh my god I can't even okay I can't even
jump up on this thing
oh my the ring is [ __ ] closing get it
I'm about to there we go got it there's
no ammo in this [ __ ] though only got
six shots be careful I'm about to die
like I need some [ __ ] health a
syringe that was me god I got sniper you
mark you get out of your stupid game
here's what your [ __ ] dumbass game
dude
Jesus Christ it's good a million per
game are you playing for money get the
[ __ ] out of that game
I don't see I got a better webcam coming
y'all so like my face forehead is it
gonna look like a ghost
when I get my cuz I got an old-school
logitech from my 10 years ago but here
we are see what the Chad has to say face
that's like it doesn't make you since
we're half - people are like oh the
audio is good and then the other half
it's like oh no but I think I fixed it I
know I had a thing plugged in this
should've been plugged in so I'm just
trying to like figure it out now just oh
how is it now Wow [ __ ] you hold on
reloading down anyway so I'm gonna check
yours Erik check check check check check
check check check one check watch it -
Mic Check
[Music]
yeah we ran into that we should have let
the private
wait what
okay there we go
yeah I'm according to my check
everything sounds good on your stream
Eric alright thank you I'm telling you
man people are just like just like big I
should just have a button on my thing
called you just push Griffin's button
it's just Eric Eric yelling on his
channel is [ __ ] up my ears no I
thought they're in chat my turn my
volume down a little bit just kids when
I start to scream oh here we go
my friend hey doing their art their way
to be a was us too
it's free it was [ __ ] that's scary
does his own thing like a piece of [ __ ]
like always with the team Frank oh [ __ ]
there's guys over here oh my god there's
guys oh my god I'm gonna die just guys
right behind me I like watching I'm
gonna get sectors whole family just
let's see where's the blue I'm in a
place where there's no escape I'm in a
room by myself I look around let me know
can I
should we hit these first I don't know
there's two guys and I only have a hand
case two squads to our left let's drop a
hot drop on your face that's what I drop
off yes that's why ooh
I'm going up here what are just a punk
that you're playing alone no no it's
hey buddy wait so the verdict in the end
was no it's not my fault there's some
guys who are right Jessie Asian Rihanna
so they got Asia Rihanna she's blazing
for sure she's Blazers she's for sure
America's Next
[Music]
give me that bye-bye
we've got all that stuff alright where
where are we
we're not too far
oh we're like how do we keep doing this
to ourselves got my sights
I said we'd go through I said we go
through but we got to be careful as many
dudes in there
[Music]
whoa [ __ ] the [ __ ] peacekeeper right
in front of my face I was right I took
the game here we go here we go come back
in this room come back in this room
there's a guy I got a ninja star guys
[Music]
I ought to just zoom out of here I'm
healing nightmare
can I grapple them or something no no no
it's just not I'm out of all my [ __ ]
[ __ ] anybody got oh my god [ __ ] out
along my health let's go let's go there
we go
[Music]
cover our back come back my god this guy
just stabbed me I need to heal he's got
shotgun also Jersey what's out first
shotgun ow oh I think they're coming
from behind they're coming from behind
alright let's close it well this is our
last stand boys you gotta make
encounters help help help me guys here
they come I want that boy just dawn wow
that hurt me a lot whatever he just did
to me hurt me a lot shoot
hey don't go oh there's another crazies
down
why is the only two of us know he's
there I made it gets dammit
yeah we need to push it on those other
two yeah we should not all the problems
I didn't know damn good two of them down
I got that fat guy down well I got yeah
you got that guy wanted knocking down
you guys tomorrow morning I got under
editors workaholics well that's my next
episode over for book referred Griffin
here's our jump master what oh really no
not to tell you Billy Bob Jim Joe Jim
Joe Jackson
let's call us Stevie's at Griffin's
meditating I see two teams to the right
bottom right directly should have pushed
those best shooter you're right okay
guns galore
daddy is ready to go watching a hard
turner it's painful watching you Arthur
I'm surprised he hasn't talked in a
while
why is he so quiet because I kept saying
okay I'm gonna stay with you mad cuz I'm
here what happens can I say brother
you're not kicking nobody our third what
does you Todd
I didn't say that swear it god are we
good up there
oh there we go here comes this [ __ ] oh
he passed it
let's go this way
Sam take that look at this gun should I
take up this guy oh I think I see you
asking full-auto shotgun that's better
right now oh this might go this is great
oh and a blue backpack yes now work now
we're cooking y'all all right okay the
two guns I want to wrap the bow I'm
happy let me follow these guys see this
is what happens when I'm looking for
[ __ ] they're gone there's no word like
hey we're leaving yeah yeah yeah yeah
you do okay this is a father of the Year
guys
hi there fight oh yes
oh [ __ ] you guys are now I want you to
Archie's I know
I mean wonder why I get killed yeah yeah
we know why you get killed you know what
coke I swear to god these are my
teammates - here's the perfect loadout
wingman and peacekeeper both together
over my house over here yep I hear
someone over here where you come grab so
nice grab this I already have one of
these perfect
no damn nurse yeah well we're done with
that bunch of bodies every wait okay oh
my god peacekeeper let's push them coz
we grab the stuff alright let's go well
we're coming we're close to circle
who's getting good stuff over here where
are you guys open that door healing my
wounds I'm healing my okay there's
nothing in here going on are we going
circle I got someone above me all right
where we going
don't you see that what Frank already
took everybody what is it
go to my room I'll take it he's in the
house above you bottom who the other guy
there's another guy coming from your
left
yeah you can take it I just wished it
was a finisher oh [ __ ]
tap him in the head I'm trying to get
you in Logar how that happened
they're healing the school them in there
I brought up are we not in the circle
we're not in the circle at all we're
right all three of them are in there all
right I got two all right here we go
Shem off somebody yeah they're right
over right here I see you
this is our top the roof to all you won
over oh [ __ ] look out on the sky oh my
god snowing bomb oh my god where I got
my shield
oh [ __ ] really what this guy can
discover my shooters like a blast feet
oh my god
give me up give it up okay
oh my god I can't believe you survived
that that was incredibly got me right in
the middle of using a service sucked I
don't know why should I use my super oh
my god how do you use your shield thing
recharging shield there you go do it
again
and one more charging shield
sar need some ammo oh I'm gonna need
some ammo soon oh my god even playing
with the team Arthur you just like
soloing stuff I don't know what this is
we're not talking are Corsa I'm focusing
I'm in a game are you mad gonna have a
group meeting I told you I tried to push
guy behind us
let's do swamps again bulgar I just mark
let's go over here here just on the
right jump and go right
watch out Chancellor just go to this
little left here oh my god oh my god
somebody come get ready try to get back
wait Frank I'm coming towards you let's
go there's two of them there hold on I
got a heel
chat no win for me
let's try to draw man snow you long
knife for you keep them busy with school
yeah podcast Griffin with Griffin
I've been done a podcast person there
somebody asked me on this calls behind
you I think I heard something but I'm
not sure how much we need gaming channel
gasps he's cool but you know obviously
he's gonna start off with three three
and a half million views like he is now
what
yeah it seen him and Wilson it's
starting it's not fair this [ __ ]
Amy he's dangerous
you say you took my god this could be it
where are you going to go into the
circle all right let's go
I'll show you let's try to stay on the
outside over there I need to grab I got
a little how much you have how much I
grab anything else turn my grenade I can
give you what you want [ __ ] he's
above us they're way over there let's go
throught people over this way why'd you
guys go that way oh my god come back
here come back here come back here what
is this
once two squads left here let's let's
come around let's come around to Bolger
here oh they're pushing we're coming
towards you bulgar just uh I'm running
block we got to go down to come up I've
ogre come toward us we're come toward us
I know what he had we're coming to you
we're coming to you all right I got a
shotgun a wingman is it's gonna be close
range let them fight I want to make sure
I got a good spot see the shadow out
this window ready to go to hole right
there I'm coming up - I just wanna get
rolled up on I don't see him up here he
was saying that Jack Black's do not to
hang out with this kid more I think it's
great
hey it's like I think your trip there's
no build up necessary he's already got
such I think that was like the shadow
though use and stuff alright um maybe we
should shot I'm gonna shoot up this way
on the left let's go this way get deeper
okay I think but every week he promises
Oh next week we'll do gaming and then
the next week their game
we're gonna hit the circle right now Wow
do you mean we that guy that guy had to
get you up you're dead up there's guys
in front of us yeah closing exactly I
got three kills yeah how much how much
damage compared to a 513 come back come
back come back right here I got I gotta
get out of the way that's Frank's look
at the store nobody's coming from here
this way we gotta go it's coming from
this way over here we are in a middle of
a battle here shut your faces oh my god
good streams everybody's being quiet
let's stay right hallways I agree
Frank yeah no Frank Oh cuz we're in
we're in the third circle dude okay I
got it I got a shield ready to go too
oh my my super is not gonna be good in
here right cuz it's not gonna
they have to come in here right oh my
god
hey coke I'm opening all the doors so
they're facing out are you oh yes yes
yes I'm on the tube I'm gonna - Eric
time I mean yep yep their fight I just
saw how many comments I gave you for
that Jack Black comment here well
straight to you Griffin did you see that
not gonna come from the back right whoa
[ __ ] I ran out of bullets already I
don't have any bullets this is a
nightmare
go the back [ __ ] close the door
on me who you what are you talking about
now I'm headed to the door and I'm gonna
[ __ ] door got closed on me second
place
dang where's my score oh my god that was
that was nerve-racking I think if we got
one more in me to try to give me a win
let's go basketball if you have 75
points but your team loses it wasn't a
good effort okay
[Laughter]
I'll call my god this [ __ ] rape it be
coke we played very well yeah we did we
did oh yeah somebody sent me $6.99 thank
you
they just had enough
[Music]
[Music]
yeah for sure
cuz [ __ ] Frank doesn't know how to
play the game people down here that's
Frank's favorite thing to say is what
are you talking about I know I know so
yeah now you want me to know you guys
might give us your backpack
there's a guy right here oh this is just
gonna kill you man he was stupid yes
give me just a gas card then you see
somebody ha ha cheapens the game she
cheapens your soul
I mean I'm coming I'm coming wait for me
grows we're running way away from the
circle though it doesn't matter [ __ ]
cheap [ __ ] that Nayar girl has a cheap
[ __ ] move
which one okay
next Griffin's gonna play spin the
bottle you're asking chat that's the
Knicks game Monopoly yep be fun seven
minutes seven minutes in heaven by
yourself Monopoly whatever is anyone
ever finished a monopoly game I don't
well there's always some dick with all
the good [ __ ] you're just like I'm out
yeah he's just waiting for you to get to
like boardwalk or some [ __ ]
yeah I'm sure
hey this ship is landing right here how
do you know does it show you if this
animals good for you or not oh oh I got
no scopez ooh don't want this no I don't
want this all right compare how many you
check this [ __ ] out
oh yeah people stay on it
well flank them to 11 I'm all about that
backpack like they're in the water Oh
what is the way we possession oh you
took it hey I'm coming and I'm getting
this good run it
I don't know why my guys so slow oh man
I have a long boat but I don't have any
[ __ ] ammo for this [ __ ]
oh my god yeah well she phased out she
phased out I'm hitting in that balloon
friends I mean she moved away from like
hella far away I would just go try with
a balloon why do so she's upset
oh there's two we do house lineup this
and then it it gives you the boost again
then they push it on you when I was
before I see that's alright I like this
chick she's pretty good Tommy Miller
gave you five bucks this men didn't give
me a song when I gave him five bucks I'm
not talking to you I'm singing to you oh
my god I'm not gonna make it look at
this
it's [ __ ] oh let's do it killing me
right now [ __ ] do it
oh my god I'm real you want to go there
oh my god he's our a [ __ ] oh my god I
hate I guess you got that rig for the
ship right oh [ __ ] I didn't make it
bigger we didn't make it I don't have
any Hills oh Jesus Christ
this [ __ ] [ __ ] I need some there's
purple chestplate whatever is all thank
you
yeah Frank still works at the Comedy
Store he's a busboy I'm coming nobody
nobody chicken wings like Frank I'm
telling you that right now
how to get that honey mustard oh [ __ ] so
we shooting at me behind me behind me
behind this rock oh yeah they're running
up on you now
maybe we should go too
[Music]
let's do it yeah that's not even a
choice I don't know
he left us just you need let's you want
to leave don't start shooting hey guys
we got this
Rando with us he bribed his way onto the
fire team
[Laughter]
I donated after I sure for a simple five
dollar donation you can play with us
apparently but you got to go - pika TV
first then you get to the big with the
big boys I know you mad you can't say
that every time dude you can't go I'm
just kidding Craig after you've already
talked [ __ ] it's too late the damage is
done
that's correct projecting he doesn't
want it doesn't like banana yeah hey I'm
the one who invited just yeah but it's a
setup
it's literally conferred wants to
suddenly talk [ __ ] but I'm right bananas
face
no no yes my boy I don't know about him
we're not gonna sit here a [ __ ] like
he's not weird I mean we know he's I
mean yeah I mean he started ours how
much do you do have to get through pica
before you can get on this you can't be
like that one guy so you see anything
people how much damage does the ninja
stars do as you can hear right now
Craig's upset that he's losing I'm
actually kicking his ass what's in here
you can only hold two things and two
stars that wants in one slot no I'm good
with all this guy's pissing me off
okay I'll just move to a circle yeah
there's another thing over here coke
frosty
I didn't have it with Craig mean heels
this guy's piece of [ __ ] like all those
all right these guys gone already taking
off em oh damn it energy em have you
know [ __ ] this guy I wanna let's go
[Music]
I'm choosing this guy right now I just
choose [ __ ] pissing where you see
somebody
right here [ __ ] yeah
come on nightmare what are you doing
god there's somebody right there oh my
god come over here
you come come around oh [ __ ] this guy's
[ __ ] shooting at me come on my shield
gonna kill at least two oh I got two
kills yeah what just looking at the
stats I feel like you didn't do you did
[Laughter]
no not tonight though okay one more I
guess that's it are we done one more you
got 140 people watching you brother
shut up what did you just say yep he
said Beretta why oh my god this guy's
[ __ ] that's it oh look it's a Z J he
gave you 20 bucks Griffin you got to
play another game are you playing Arthur
all of your money give me all your money
you know entertaining okay here we go
hello UK listeners and followers people
from the UK we get a lot of euros coming
in right now some euro people
[Music]
what's all that muffin with Griffin
verge or Spartanburg as you can see I'm
wearing a worst part team jersey right
now oh yeah are you happy yeah gamer goo
I forgot about the game or goods from me
people donate five bucks you know they
can take all your grenades dollars he
thinks he can take
talking about piece of [ __ ] tune in
tomorrow on ders on the river pika
people do a job let's go here I'm
wearing right now for $100 donation I
will send it when I was sleep I was
sleeping it and then Koch will promptly
find out whoever bought it and find out
where they live and just smack them I
[Laughter]
don't have a gun oh my god
hey I got a VK 47 flat line over here if
you need it just it's a gun just say I
have a gun
[Laughter]
here is quick to integrate on this home
[Music]
it was a good one actually I only have
one more I have two more workaholics
people to have on the podcast Adam and
Wayman wayman's gonna be on to build
this far away hey did you hear what this
guy just say he said what about Montez I
could maybe maybe maybe hey I'm gonna
hit this this wire and go top yeah we're
coming okay bro those guys all together
have like this that's a deep cut
workaholics fan right there if you if
you if you're claiming ghosts man you
really watch this man was the guy that
always had the law polo tie on
whose whose jets cost ten bucks just to
send it my favorite episode is with him
in and he had line in it those that
cracked me up there's just a scene that
cracked me up funny funny find a [ __ ]
I'm going over to fat yeah that is a
huge huge blow like the way everybody's
laughing I'm like he knows oh [ __ ]
I got multiple Phoenix kids over here oh
I got two Phoenix - I need that better
secondary I got nothing good for second
man alright we got seven squads left
Bobby ain't gonna play no why do they
always ask about Bob and Steve they're
dead they're dead to us
they're dead oh it's this way but I'm
trying to get down here yeah but that's
away from the sort where we're doing
another no but I need I need a secondary
they're gonna be on next asking what
games they play right now
no that's fine both you have officially
got your balls removed no oh oh well
being that guy I just keep it real
teammates died that guy yeah
you just I survived that's yeah that's
behind us
no we're headed towards it right now
we're headed towards the shooting I know
I super thing I got twenty actually
light rounds light rounds I got this
boundary we go along curliness gotta go
to circle they're fighting over there
let's stay back let's go hi over on the
left II stay back there fighting okay
you leave okay where are you guys oh
they're right here yeah what'd you say
let's go cross let's go cross go cross
go cross while they're fight
not them I'm cutting off we're to the
right let's hang out here to the right
here let's hang out here yep bring his
closing hit one some good news a
shocking shows I need second you need
lights go bright let's go bright let's
go right up here
let's go bright up here be careful there
was once one that one I see one right
there I think we're good right now oh I
was shooting the gun I knocked down
it's like my gun doesn't work okay right
all right let's hold up let's just stay
in the circle when I do good damage coke
doesn't say [ __ ] [ __ ] you had 278 off
yours you just threw I was not I was
shooting the guy
no you were shooting a box you didn't
land anything in that last that last
thing behind us fracking this is
nerve-racking this guy I got this guy I
killed him I killed on the road they're
all dead we killed them yeah it was
insta the last one yeah here i got i got
mad chat hall today they were good all
right
do we have another one in us he could
shield
you guys got shields is the last one the
last one
ooh body armor I need that No let's get
another alright let's go I wasn't
playing all right now
it was long playing all right
what was that accident accident
you're such an [ __ ] dude come over
this way follow me I'm following you bro
rota air strike oh my god I swear to god
let's go let's go let's go let's go let
them fight it out let them find it out
for spy cover
let's go swamps Alps let's hit that
building he just told you piece of [ __ ]
get in here get in here they're coming
right now let's hold up
here
we get this help
I need shields all right let him find it
Hannah all right I'm going inside here
watching the store you watch that door
uh-huh
there's no [ __ ] guns in here man oh
my god this is so annoying when there's
no girl here's a guy on me hide you down
a guy already Jesus Christ what they saw
us Arthur just hanging let them let it
come out let them go after you are you
aiming at there we go see they're
killing each other we act let's exit
this door and go to the left over there
like again across the wall Oh was that
you yeah fine can't you just pick it up
again already let's go this way
believe in me and you so am i cover you
yeah literally just run away which we
got it we gotta weigh the pros and cons
is it really worth it I'll make your
life a living hell
this is my last appearance on the show
hey just carry
run run run [ __ ] where's Arthur
I need money to buy weed
all right now let me take that
snow-covered coat I'll be right back my
back is just be coming back yes yeah
that was like the worst death ever I
literally fell off the side and I have
some good [ __ ] too
they were waiting for me it is so you
guys are dead I'm not dead close to let
me wait opposing pros and cons if I
should come say there ain't no way in
hell you do jack [ __ ] no listen it is BS
[Laughter]
in fact I die it's over here way over
here I can't even get the sand out
can I even get to it he was taking a
piss is it up here I'm not gonna make it
alright what are we doing
let's go too late
why'd you break away cry I think you're
good come on come on friend that's what
I'm saying oh here we go
here we go there it is I see it let's
see what happened pinging that's so
weird yeah right oh you want problems
right there but it was from this one I
rescued oh [ __ ] y'all
now let's get cook of the Rings nothing
no I'm trying Oh
you guys alright this bro whoo got
golden armor
cs1 talking about no guns
I have no no I have like one [ __ ]
gun I have a grenade now dude I don't
think anyway okay how do we get yeah if
this is the one that you get a win on
[Music]
now that we have your negativity off the
team maybe without sake I got a golden
enemies over here I'm gonna see if they
left us any gun right here I don't have
any scope think somebody shot at me and
the edges circle to see oh I got a shot
a pistol shotgun are solid good Wow and
a backpack great one heavy ammo oh
here's a re 45 think I should get enough
is this so I gotta test this all right I
got a shoot yeah energy ammo
Wow
okay wait do I have it like a little
arrow I mean we did good we gaming
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
[ __ ] watching and thanks for all your
donations and tomorrow you exactly this
piece of [ __ ] is doing my commercial for
me alright